اذا مشاهدينا الكرام كما ذكرنا فهناك
تفاصيل مهمه يجب معرفتها عن خريطه الخرطوم
بدرجه اساسيه لنتعرف كيف تدور الاشتباكات
الخرطوم تتكون من ثلاث اقسام كما ذكرنا من
اكثر من مناسبه هذا القسم الذي يسمى خرطوم
بحري الجهه الشرقيه والشماليه الشرقيه من
الخرطوم الكبرى المحافظه وايضا نتحدث عن
مدينه الخرطوم التي تتكون من جزء والتي
تشكل الجزء الجنوبي من مدينه او من
الخرطوم الكبرى وبقي ام درمان التي تشكل
الجزء الغربي او الشمالي الغربي من محافظه
الخرطوم الكبرى هذه المدن الثلاث التي
تتكون منها العاصمه السودانيه اليوم
الهدوء كان سيد الموقف بشكل كبير مع دخول
هذه الهدنه الساعات الاولى مع تحليق
للطيران التابع للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم
بحري وام درمان هذا التحليق بطبيعه الحال
ردت عليه قوات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه لكن لم يسجل
سقوط ضحايا حتى هذه اللحظه مع انه قبل
قليل كان هناك حديث عن اندلاع اشتباكات في
منطقتي كادرو والحلفايه في المنطقه الوسطى
من الخرطوم بحري شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري
في هذه المنطقه على حوالي
تقريبا 30 كيلومتر شمالي النهر شمالي نهر
النيل الازرق الذي الاتي من اثيوبيا كان
هناك اشتباكات قبل قليل نتحدث طبعا عن
منطقه الخرطوم الجنوبيه او الجنوب الجنوب
الخرطوم هذه المنطقه التي نتحدث عنها بشكل
اساسي التي كانت مسرح العمليات خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه يتحدث الجيش
السوداني بانه ينفذ حتى هذه اللحظه عمليات
تمشيط من المنطقه الجنوبيه باتجاه الشمال
مدينه الرياضيه وجبرا والصحافات قبل قليل
كان مراسلنا في منطقه السوق المركزي في
محيط المدينه الرياضيه ولكن العمليات
العسكريه تتركز بشكل اساسي في شمالي مدينه
الخرطوم
هدوء هدوء كان هدوء المنطقه كل هذه
المنطقه كانت منطقه هاديه بشكل كبير كانت
هذه المنطقه هادئه بشكل كبير كما ذكر
عثمان ولكن العمليات العسكريه تركزت في
المنطقه الشماليه من مدينه الخرطوم
وتحديدا محيط مطار الخرطوم صوره اقرب لهذه
المنطقه هذه المنطقه التي نتحدث عنها مطار
الخرطوم ومركز القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه والقصر الجمهوري هذا هذه الدائره
او هذا المربع
المليء او المكتظ بالاحياء السكنيه الذي
يتكون بشكل اساسي من مطار الخرطوم مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه وايضا
القصر الجمهوري بالاضافه الى عدد من
الوزارات وزاره الداخليه وزاره الخارجيه
وعدد من المحاور المهمه هذه هي المناطق
التي تشهد الاشتباكات وتحديدا اكثر
المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من المطار
الخرطوم المنطقه الشماليه حي المطار من
مطار الخرطوم وايضا محيط القصر الجمهوري
لماذا لانه قوات الدعم السريع تمركزت في
هذه المواقع منذ ما قبل اندلاع هذه
الاشتباكات وبالتالي كانت هذه المنطقه هي
ابرز المناطق في الاشتباكات طبعا مع توقف
الحركه بشكل نهائي في مطار الخرطوم منذ
اليوم الاول او منذ الساعات الاولى بعد
دخول قوات الدعم السريع تقول قوات الجيش
انها تمشط هذه الاحياء او بقوات راجله
بطبيعه الحال بحثا عن مقاتلي الدعم السريع
مزيد من التفاصيل والتحليل ستكون مع عثمان
والضيوف